[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lorsqu'à l'époque de la noël un
provençal reçoit chez lui ce qu'il
appelle un étranger c'est à dire toute
personne même française mais au dessus
de 45 degrés de latitude nord passé
balance par conséquent et au delà de 4
degrés de longitude ouest passé niveau
par conséquent il lui demandera dans un
coin de la maison
la crèche aménagé pour les enfants et
les adultes l'étranger se pince voix de
petits personnages colorés à tenir
le provençal pause l'index sur la tête
des symptômes aider celui là voyez vous
c'est l'enjeu bouffard et où celui ci le
pêcheur c'est de la gr c est grâce est
et au moment où l'étranger commencent à
poser des questions et invariablement le
diable tous un joyeux brandon dans la
gorge les convives le bruit les
chasseurs et le cliquetis des verres qui
trinquent couvre la voix du narrateur la
fête gonfle nre et disparaît du
calendrier l'étranger à rejoigne les
régions boréales
ils ne sont à jamais qui était le
pêcheur grasset grâce à leur avis
d'autres encore
jusqu'à aujourd'hui car aujourd'hui
étrangers je vais te conduire auprès des
centaines à dormir
e
[Musique]
à
le
le peur et l'âne
oui c'est super bowl fort là la
mythomanie bon alors on l'a lu et
ouvriers parlent qu'il faut souffler oui
sont le futur pour le réchauffer oui ces
arbres le temps long les gens là j'obéis
pas le goal com fait meuf laboureur
fameux souffleur qui fut celui là
d'abord 12e ce genre dans l'eau au sable
pour me le faut au plus haut que la
fenêtre est plus haut que les toits plus
haut que la colline sur main et plus
haut peut-être que vol l'épervier
c'était une voix accompagnée d'un
tonnerre de dieu
le haut une voie maîtresse et commande
une espèce de voix formidable
et la voix d'ici et il se passera d'ici
le matin des choses autour de cet enfant
comme on n'en a jamais vu ça sonne faux
tout primo fait un fils de grace et
n'eurent se collent nous nous sommes au
premier en place à lui souffle aux
[Musique]
attentes sur mer mais cette question
souffle pas quand même bref le fils du
seigneur est mûr pour une grand rire
c'est toujours où la tramontane et le
siroco est un peu le sens des nuances
souffle à définir souffle en douceur un
souffle en doute eu soufflera tiède dans
des calmes sous plateforme tu souffres
ma peau pas l'emblème paul dalla
[Musique]
le phenom bar bulles et la petite et a
finalement tout année elle de la lumière
sont les jours q c'est la petite c'est
la mère de l'enfant tout ni l'homme
c'est celui qui lui sauve la réputation
de 3 d'affaires moi je te le dis une
affaire avec mystère en jusqu'au bord
avec commun comme une tare fun de cindy
en tout cas tu sais vraie manne ça on le
saura avant que le soleil sorte lui et à
la tintin lui faut tout faire pour rien
avoir à se reprocher en attendant faute
y croire le souffle au souffle m
[Musique]
l'âge bouffard dans la crèche de saturn
l'âme je vous ferai a occupé la
situation la plus ridicule et la plus
pénible
on l'a suspendu par une boucle de fil de
fer il est là entre ciel et terre et y
tierra la mène une trompette moi j'ai
toujours trouvé qu'il était bizarre même
placé d'abord et qu'ensuite on lui
donnait un physique de chérubins et
joufflu qui correspond pas du tout à ses
attributions
car en fait qui était ce la région
bouffard a ni plus ni moins que
l'annonciateur luton bétail
le louis amstrong démesurée de cet
événement stupéfiants moi moi je le vois
un costaud avec un coffre solide il
perdait le qui vous permettez monsieur
je vais m'expliquer ma mère à votre
convenance bel âge oui moi je suis longe
bouffard et où vous saurez où ça veut
dire qu'il souffle des toute l'éternité
feu devait être celui qui souhaiterait
dans la trompette au moment où jésus est
né alors faites moi l'honneur d'écouter
toutes les notes gars maintenant je me
bouche
attention attention mais ravit pas le
petit mais le petit nourrir à l'oeil que
l'arrivée des bergers monsieur c'est
écrit tout est organisé sa vie sa
passion sa mort et sa résurrection
il n'y a que mon sort qui n'est pas
réglé qu'est ce qu'on va faire des
longues bouffard et où après son
contrôle est je suis très angoissé la
dernière seconde allait aller ne tarde
plus fait confiance quand on ne peut que
le groupe est même l'âne et le boeuf
tendre l'oreille le mufle attention
attention je souffle
m
voilà je remonte au ciel c'était joli
ah oui as-tu pour partir à présent je
n'ai pas d'angoissé aller à dieu le dieu
vous paraît la poissonnière l'un des
center mais plus connu c'est la
poissonnière on la reconnaît à ce que à
la maladie
eagle à bambi
venez le mandla mandela mandla mandela
man 2 mai
et à ce petit jeu vous fait peut
rapprocher
je suis grand saut mais je n'ai jamais
quand ces personnes sauf mari pêcheur de
l'humanité petit elle est forte en
gueule mais c'est la profession qui le
veut et puis la concurrence ce qu'ils
exigent
parce que tu es sûr à marseille sur le
vieux-port les evans et en scène côte à
côte et j'ai aussi des anguilles et
fiston déchirait les n'est pas tacler
des moules de bouzigues
higuain des moules de bouzigues été
violée
et tout ça tu as la même frais qu'une
fois cuites çà bouge encore
je vous le jure sur la tête je le
receveur delargy stoner et menteuse
pour ban dans sa marchandise elle
aimerait père et mère bombay où gary
approchez approchez d'abord si c'est une
automobile que vous voulez acheter ou le
pire de bretelles c'est pas la peine de
rester devant des passants mais vous
vous regardez mes rascasse comme si vous
atteignez que le voici devenu poésie ou
alors si vous voulez acheter chez la
voisine la banque de la rue ne voulait
pas du tout de suite comment je n'ai pas
de temps à perdre mes skis étaient les
cordes vocales seulement écouter écouter
même peu entre nous soit dit ce poisson
lequel van heel et avant-hier si ça me
pourrit c'est par pudeur son mari c'est
une filiation à cette femme
il va pécher que les jours impairs
encore s'il n'y a pas de vagues quand on
cherche un caillou dans la mer il dit
que ça la tempête et il bouge pas dans
la maison possède maintenant une fête le
comité pourquoi cette matrone âme à la
mouche et figure dans l'accord mais
qu'est ce que j'aime terre quelque part
jacques est là pourquoi je figure dans
la cache me dit si ça vous gêne il faut
le dire
et si vous me le dit que je pourrais pas
de moi j'ai pas lu malinga d'olivier
pour la faire sécher vous savez non mais
des fois que tu raconte jason robards
voilà oraux ou mettez pas en colère
j'aime peu perdu les détails ça arrive à
tout le monde mais bien les voilà les
détails je vous a donné un pelé couffé
mois de détails
d'abord il faut vous dire que la nuit où
l'un je bouffe areva 30 pt pour que tout
le monde ne se rendent à la crèche le
premier mouvement
ça a été de sauter du lit de passer le
caraco le plus fleuri et le jupon le
plus beau des et hop
sur la route de bt l'un mais alors comme
les bergers à porter les agneaux les
plus beaux les meuniers la farine la
plus fine et chacun ce qu'il avait de
plus précieux
moi mon dieu les bras m'en sont tombés
des épaules qu'est ce que j'avais deux
précieux mais poissons et oui c'était
pas transportable et n'ont jusque là et
je vous le fais pas dire ouais et l'eau
il met repasser par la coucourde
que le jour de la fête des poissonniers
que fut nommée reine du vieux port un
oui il ya longtemps
et alors le président de la corporation
me fie qu'à doodle bocal en verre de
biot et dans ce bocal nager un poisson
japonais à 12 couleurs 12
monaco n'est que 7ème batteur en avait
12 ans et si vous ne croyez pas c'est
que vous avez du grossier
cette couleur cette couleur mais il a 70
de couleur dans la nature bref c'est ce
que vous aviez de plus précieux et oui
alors je prends le bocal est en route
avec tout le monde qui sonne à l'est à
travers les mers les montagnes le pool
idée dans son bocal
mon dieu on aurait dit qu'il comprenait
dit c'est intelligent ces petites bêtes
que vous savez il ajouté ses mâchoires
sa longue queue chatoyantes comme de la
gorge de pigeons
c'était le roi des poissons je lui
donnais des grains de shionogi je lui
changer l'eau à chaque étape
mais alors elle peut savoir si justement
ce changement nous vous savez ce
changement de régime en somme lui
portait pas sur l'estomac au fur et à
mesure qu'on avance et hyper des ses
couleurs karakash a été en vue je jette
un regard sur le petit japonais bons
numéros de zinc
il était déjà presque couchée à la
surface l'oeil déjà clock que vous savez
la lumière de sa belle robe assez
théniers de minute en minute
ça bouge ça voulait dire où je meurs je
meurs je meurs je me je me suis avancé
et la mort dans l'âme j'ai découvert le
joli bocal de mon fichu que ce qu'on vit
qu'une fois
et quand tout le monde à genoux devant
l'enfant atteint nous sommes présents
rouge de rente
j'ai dit que ce que je raconte j'ai dit
j'ai bégayé j'ai bafouillé j'ai pleuré
j'ai rien à envier aux guerriers mau
lyonnaise j'ai un poisson mort au jeu me
reverrait toute ma vie et je te le fichu
de 2 sur le poker est une lumière dans
hors montréal éclate dans la crèche vous
croyez pas que nous sommes dit le
poisson était ressuscité
ah non il était bien mort le pauvre il
avait rendu son âme à dieu mais à sa
place j zay un poisson en diamant
topazes
hop et j'en passe parce que fut une
grosse ignorante
mais toutes les pierres précieuses y est
et on peut vous croire vous l'avez
garder je me garde ne le regardais les
pavots lui je le donnais dit je suis
revenu plus pauvres mais certaines
amplifiant cavernes et vous savez moi il
faut que je gagne ma vie et c'est que je
suis seulement parmi les morts et à
trois fois le clown merlin c'est pas le
maître vous pourrez fortune à l'ailé
mais vous le nobel comment voyez quand
même thann à la barbie
guingamp vous l'aurez vu vous demeurez
dessus
vers le mans de l'amendement de la maxi
calme aujourd'hui 1
venez le monde le monde de l'amendement
de l'amendement de l'amendement de venir
moi on m'appelle leur avis je suis celui
qui lève les bras en l'air en faisant m
et pourquoi je fais aux mêmes parce que
je suis ravi je suis ravi de voir une
femme naître dans une étable
je suis ravi de tout depuis que je suis
née que je sait distinguer une figue
d'une gousse d'ail
je roule comme une balle d'étonnement en
étonnement de ravi ce même un
ravissement nous soyez sincère vous
peignez de vos douleurs
vous avez toujours une main sur les
côtes ou ne la remet à la paupière vous
grenier contre le choix le foie canton
le sur le pas sur vous cherchez toujours
le quai duquesne du pourquoi du comment
me vois le mois de juin
à part la mort qu'est ce qui est grave
vous n'êtes pas ravis de vivre et que
hier ne ressemble pas à vannes pierre ni
demain à aujourd'hui il le rire des
filles et la couleur des blés et la
couleur des cheveux des filles qui
ressemble à celle des plaies s'avoue
ravi pas à moi à mon avis qu'est ce que
voulez que je vous dise je ne me fais
pas je me ferai jamais je suis ravi
d'être là que sûr ravis de vivre et
l'univers continue à apporter ses
trésors et je peux pas me rassasier
je reviens mais le thème est plus nuancé
et moins j'en sais je mourrais à vingt
dieux ravira un ravi qui ne se lassait
pas des trois ravie je serais mort de
mon propre avis mme
[Musique]
la fileuse
de cette philosophie est assise au coin
de la crèche comme isolé des autres
symptômes ne me frappe est nulle ou nuls
a connu ces temps où les fortes
ordinaire c'est une que nous y sommes
particularités mais j'ai été frappé par
la figure de la fileuse et elle m'a
sauté aux yeux
cette figure si je puis dire regardez la
terrible reine couture et brident
allongée presque jaune on voudrait
savoir le pourquoi de ses babines crispé
pourquoi qu'elle ne porte guère
attention aux autres pourquoi elle a
l'air d'être resté comme comme
l'intérieur d'une coquille
il se trouve que moi je sais
et c'est c'est une curieuse histoire
d'abord son nom
disons qu'elle s'appelle estelle quel
tel aviv interne
c'est un prénom qui lui allait comme un
gant de velours elle a traversé la ville
de brignoles avec une auréole de lumière
autour de sa chevelure vénitienne la
taille aussi fine que celle d'une
libellule et son cotillons découvre à
l'effort de miss travail des jeunes à
faire crever d'orage la fin du stage
bref une fille attiré autant de galères
que nos l'alternateur de falaise et ce
cas là vous avez combien l'amour dit
haut de 16 à 20 m un chapelet de vfm 5 1
quelques bonne brochette de benchikha 31
oui mais de qualité sinon une quantité
mais ça veut dire 80 vous avez pas
encore la bague au doigt ça ça veut dire
qu à brignoles il ne se trouvait pas une
âme pour me tourner la cervelle et le
reste et il aime défilé à la maison de
mon père est force d'avoir eu à lui le
nez qui me fallait alors train la bouche
qui me plaisait à une troisième le
sourire qui me tombent les j'avais fini
1 réunissant les morceaux à me faire une
idée de l'homme qui aurait dit oui tout
de suite et il est venu sur mes 31ème
bout comme un séjour jeu
ailleurs flamme d'amour et par dessus le
marché du québec mais ruini c'est un
milliard il me disait je n'ai à te
donner que mon nous et c'est un homme
plein d'honneur mais l'honneur ne paye
pas une assiette de soupe que marc fès
ville à vis de toi comme visa midi
viable à passer pour un coureur de du
catr garde le bas de laine qui tu viens
de te perds tu veux ou l'amérique pour
faire fortune
il se doit du reste elle s'est étonnée
c'est qu'elle est pendant cinq ans on a
commencé à rire quand je traversais la
place du carami ne l'atteint il a épousé
une bourge marie toi qui a répondu je me
marie avec et il y aura plus improbable
c'est le seul blocage de la laiterie
c'est sur ma couille
my est jouée à la parole igefi les pl
sanquer
de quoi faire des chemises de nuit à
toute la population mâle et femelle du
département 9 heures demain les rues
kent y aura plus un projet self locaux
de l'aisne top gabbiano on a fait
reconnaître toi le blocus du petit
caporal que dans l'angleterre privée de
rennes
tu l'as dit monfils ils ont acheté les
troupeaux entiers ils ont barré les
routes pour empêcher les retours de
talent du mels
moi je devenais folle j'allais inquiète
d'humour ndoumou chose allez le garder
pour filer ma quenouille
je file et orale a dit surveiller et à
travers mais vite parce qu'un barrage et
qui attendait le jour nous mettrait les
pouces
quelques jours jusqu'au jour jusqu'au
jour où j'ai dû des faux filet les draps
de son lit
les rideaux de masham tout ce qui
ressemblait un morceau d'aullène
quelques jours jusqu'au jour je me suis
arrêté pour vous livrer un de ces
messieurs
je me suis arrêté
je suis aperçu que ces messieurs ne
savait même plus le chemin de ma maison
je m'écarte 6ème retourné mon miroir
contre le mur et j'ai commencé à thème
j'ai commencé à thème et vous avez
combien d'années sur le doubs dit
estelle je vais 85 et vous croyez qu'ils
ont des mains des amériques
puma puma mort
qu'est-ce qu'ils reviennent j'aurai 80
des amis saddam hussein et animeront le
tournoi derrière nous et que new yorkais
comme il m'a quitté les lieux qu'une
seule idée dans ma cervelle et c'est
celle-là le retourne bolduc de mal belle
presse de castellane le seigneur de
larmes que pour une année en haut lieu
riesch a crevé deux puits de pétrole de
bp dehors que la terre le fait que le
thème que la terre
la tête
à
le pêcheur hulu pescadous le pêcheur
bonnet de laine tricot rayé braille de
toile à l'homme le plus pacifique du
monde l'oeil sur la cerise du bouchon
l'oreille endormi au bruit de la
civilisation le coeur calme la tête
paisible celui-là ça peleg a loupé il
habitait la calanque de la rougeole
entre carry le rouet et mais j'aime y
passer pour un peu simplet peut-être
parce qu'il disait souvent moi vous
savez par la pêche et c'est vrai qu'ils
étaient bang à la pêche
vous l'avez mois à l'époque la redonne
n'était qu'un village de 50 habitants au
plus fort que ce que je lis ce cas si
elle avait 30 et la preuve c'est que
quand la placarder sur le mur de la
mairie
la fiche de la mobilisation est générale
on a trouvé un homme mobilisables un
seul gars louper et quand on lui a dit
qu'il fallait faire le sort d'un il a
dit - vous savez à part la pêche mais ça
pique nique
mais on l'a poussé vers la gare il y
avait même veine d'honneur sur le qui a
quelques minutes à partir le train qui à
travers les marchés de l'est va t'amener
devant les hordes de tecktonik
il faut les ukases et a lobé mais moins
vous savez on parle il faut qu'à lober
d'un même jeu écrasé 6-1 peut aider m
sera été par des jeunes comme toi fm il
cible devienne un graal soldats la
province la plus produits de grains de
soldats depuis le pays de stu frei et
masséna est encore na sénat et les
niçois
bon ben je serai un grand guerrier
toujours le premier au feu compter sur
moi et revient loup il va avec ça et
donner moins de papier tu aimerais pour
comment tire pas dessus sinon moi je
peux rien garantir
après fait pour le mieux en mieux tout
en guitares dont lé adieu monsieur le
maire a les crocs ce visa tout le monde
est dommage tout ça je vais pas écrire
je voudrais raconter mes batailles tu
nous le dira oralement mots si elle ne
le sera que plus beau dieu te garde mon
petit il est pas devenu grand guerrier
bien entendu lui n'avait pas la vocation
à part la pêche de thon zenten il
faisait écrire par un de ses camarades
je vous raconterai tout à son retour là
où je suis je le droit de rien dire
le maire a été ému aux larmes chaque
année au 14 juillet il faisait un
discours dans lequel galaube et devenait
de plus en plus beau de plus en plus g à
son retour le village se proposait de
l'accueillir comme la famille horace
accueilli le survival des horaces et que
meurent les curiaces or vous ne
l'ignorez pas les curiaces obtenu quatre
âmes
quant à horace avais je veux dire
galoubet il est revenu à la redonne qu
en décembre 18
on n'avait plus de nouvelles de lui on
le croyait mort quand une nuit chez le
maire
et qu'elle a co monsieur vous désirez
bonjour monsieur le maire heures je suis
capable et ouais c galoubet ben oui
bonjour m bouffi quand même baignés
graco monumentale est le gallou buts et
plus mais comme sa copine et ben oui
c'est pas de ma faute à moi si j'ai
grossi a en tout cas je suis moi pour
héros black and the hero mon petit rire
apple tv on tacle mardi j'allais même
commandé le monument
réduire voire est donc pas au parti de
pâte à la main tout le temps affirmé un
chauffeur m fermer les casemates
les blockhaus les poires à quoi eh bien
tu diras tant le calvaire toujours dire
à quand même que tout fait à dix pieds
sur terre mais j'ai tout fait pas
j'avais tout l'espace ça que je voulais
j'étais d'un magasin d'habillement à
périgueux a eu lieu quel je tuerai foot
à périgueux ah ben je sais pas moi il
m'a envoyé là-bas coin d un magazine la
vie humaine
il paraît que j'ai des bons à rien dans
le maniement du fusil
je tirais sans m'en apercevoir un jour
j'ai failli tuer le général qui passe et
tu vas pas me dire en clôture à ses
quatre ans à périgueux le même messi
messi dans un magasin d'habillement et
je vous dis à distribuer des effets
militaires des capotes dit bolt si
erding des godillots
mon dieu quel malheur mais moi vous
savez attend la pêche a fait mais tu
tampa colt et je t'assure le profiteur
que pour les habitants de la redonne
l'espoir de napoléon mais qu'est ce que
je leur dis moi qui tu apprennes type le
14 juillet d'un jus de canneberge de fer
et le feu avec les lardons fumés
j'ai vu ça de ma faute à moi si j'avais
pas le management est à toi ou je fais
un malheur à pékin pour le moins je
suppose à nu
je suis 2e classe et le sergent il a dit
comme ça que s'il y avait une troisième
classe
j'ai bien failli me mettre tellement
c'est pas la vocation est mal au moins
que vous voulez le partage au tir que je
te tais toi tais toi tais toi
heureusement que tu es venu chez moi en
premier et la nuit c'est était venu vos
villages après jour on était fous tu y
es plus héros
il nous faut un héros tout le comme pas
ça pour que je passe moi sinon il faut
que tu sois un héros et le lendemain le
maire a présenté galoubet au village de
la redonne au cours du vin d'honneur
galoubet a fait sam lane le descendant
du train de port-de-bouc temps on a
trouvé un peu de grain oui pour un héros
mais quand il a commencé à raconter la
guerre tel qu'il était censé l'avoir
vécu toute la redonne mason qu'il
souffre de l'épopée passé sur la calade
allez vas-y et à l'oubli un col de nous
comment le club battu les troupes du
désert et simples braves jeunes voilà
j'avance et le premier les balles à elle
passée à côté simsim du la peur je ne
sais pas ce que c'est j'avais fini par
me faire une réputation terrible c'est
pas pour mon 21 mai car les allemands
savaient que kalou b se trouvaient dans
le secteur
la panique courait dans les tranchées
c'est comme ça qu'on les a eus
tenez exemple une fois à la grande
offensive du général nivelle
il est toujours vivant il raconte
toujours ses exploits mais a atteint sur
am3 de pêche à salluit vous savez à part
la pêche
[Musique]
grasset et grasse est le seul couple de
la crèche ils ont au moins 170 m à eux
deux et encore j'ai l'impression que je
leur âge ni dernis homme courbé chenu
super cool bras dessus bras dessous ils
sont là au rendez-vous des mages tassés
mais souriant je me suis demandé
pourquoi
grasset et grâce à elle je ne m'appelez
pas grasse est monsieur ah non non
grasset c'est le nom de mon mari on
appelait grasset à force de le voir avec
lui comme on appelait ferronnière la
femme de ce fait on vous savez du temps
du roi françois 1er
non je m'appelais pauline et j'étais
l'aide aux colons vous ne pouvez pas
vous l'imaginez l'aide aux à 100
kilomètres à la ronde
il n'y avait pas plus laides on aurait
fait un concours de laideur que j'aurais
eu la médaille un fait libre de
villeneuve les avignon a composé deux
chansons sur moi comme ma mère avait
enlevé tous les miroirs de la maison
pour pas qu'on veut me voir c'est sur le
sein il a écrit la mauvaiseté que voilà
pauline au port de landes regard de son
portrait de se voir aussi laide
elle est appelée mains des pieds boudou
c'est pas possible que je puisse se
plaire ce serait pas pour ma mère
j'irais bien me noyer pauvres grâce hunt
vous en étiez si bien haut mais je
n'étais encore plus bas monsieur pas ce
que veut le soudoyer pour de bon un jour
que j'étais le hall à voir mais c'est
encore plus difficile de mourir que de
vivre
d'abord parce qu'il y avait à peine un
pain et demi d'eau courante
ensuite des femmes qui m'ont vu de loin
se sont mis à crier et aussi parce que
grasset
matière et de la rivière à je comprends
tout chez grasset vous êtes gênés amour
et de pauline une amoureux c'est très
drôle a dit steve hay
mais même si c'était l'amour et il était
tellement les eu aussi que j'aurais pas
voulu de lui et puis à l'époque j'avais
encore un tel désespoir parce que ma
mère me répéter mon dieu tu as de beaux
yeux tu sais préparer la morue le
vendredi tu feras ce thème à l'homme
qu'on est majoré dessus tellement ils
sombreront un merci viendra veuille tout
marmite trouve son couvercle mois graal
c'est au qg le fille le voulait de moi
et d'espoir plus le moindre petit veux
me disais fameux pour femmes une seule
acceptera que tu es fâché la cour le
seul ne rien n'a pas de toit celle à qui
on ne fait pas la cour et qui fait rire
les hommes moi toi poli je suis venu à
tam et hommes pour le rhume côté et puis
leur arrivée aux puits pour la grippe
qui est venue après puis pour t'éviter
adèle c'est la dèche des cordes l as
saint-etienne sur la place jeux
promenades ou le premier d'un cerf ma
première l'aise y le charme a opéré et
monsieur je me disais mais
et la voix touche mais à la taille fine
et et puis elle a le pied mignon et puis
attention mais c'est qu'elle a les poils
shot thugs épouser une jeune fille qui
fâchent soit sa beauté sa demi volée
mais sa sottise
elle vous resterez chaud les bras et
puis elle détaille aime bien est ce que
est ce qu'elle est vraiment s'il est là
que je me suis dit et elle a les traits
noirs oui et elle a une toute petite
coquetterie dangereux et l'allée des
[ __ ] et seaway et le nez qui va
chercher le me sall me que fajr et août
a connu pareille vous faisait les mêmes
réflexions de l'a71 non non et oui oui
non
la beauté d'un homme c'est moins
important que ça lui de femmes vous
savez et puis drass et on le disait bon
et travailleurs forts et courageux pas
buffon pas coureurs à s'habiller dès le
matin ça je mente aux frais de l'insa
porte le soir
bref ces filles c'est comme tout le
monde se fiche mais après le repas le
fiel ça y est j'ai fait le discours j'ai
dit celle-là sera ma femme dit level
live le passé à partir d'aujourd'hui
vous lui devez le respect déjà et il
paraît qu'ils aient des filles qui me
trouvais beau pana au moins plus le
minutes
oui ces sept minutes je suis devenue
amoureuse de toi
grasset mais vous savez que je vous
trouve assez beau tous les deux hommes
et oui c'est ça le miracle nous ne nous
sommes beaucoup aimé voyez-vous monsieur
nous avons eu de pause en fait nous
informe que deux beaux enfants et nos
petits jeunes femmes ont eu de très
beaux seins peine est lourde au fur et à
mesure que les années passent et il se
produisit le phénomène extraordinaire
que le thème faisait sur le taux visage
ce qui fait sur les vieux pierre le
soleil le vent le froid la pluie nous
l'année li s'est adouci le portrait là
même des aînés nous a caressé et et
l'afl religieux perfectionne c'est
l'amour n'est ce pas monsieur c'est la
mort
certains ont dit maintenant de nous
grâce et grasse est toujours en brasse
est l'un l'autre ne lâche toujours il
s'attache aurenti le salto aimeront août
[Musique]
c'est la grâce que je leur souhaite
à
[Musique]